our next speaker is dr. Steven
Strittmatter he currently holds the
Vincent Coates professorship of
neurology at Yale and is a founding
director of the Yale cellular
Neuroscience
niro degeneration and repair
interdepartmental program and is a
founding director of the Yale memory
Disorders Clinic now his work has
contributed to defining the molecular
basis for brain wiring during
development and of neural repair after
adult injury in the aging brain as
laboratory has studied the cell surface
molecular interactions occurring in
degenerative dementia he has focused on
a missing link in the Alzheimer's
disease process the amyloid beta peptide
oligomers that could lead the way to new
drug based treatments and we certainly
need that when it comes to dementia
please welcome dr. Strittmatter the
subject is lost in thought
bases for brain malfunction and
Alzheimer's disease well it's a pleasure
to be here and be able to speak with you
and to hear all the previous speakers so
I guess I need to
it's coming helps coming up lost in
thought lost in computers alright
excellent so I'm gonna focus on
Alzheimer's and I think I wanted to
start just by emphasizing the need for
progress in Alzheimer's we of course
everyone in this room has probably been
affected from a loved one somebody you
know well with Alzheimer's and and it's
a disease that that really robs us of
what we're about our intellect our
understanding what makes us human and
I'm not going to belabor that or
emphasize it I'm gonna put up a few
slides that emphasize the the
epidemiology of Alzheimer's and why it's
a huge social issue beyond the the
personal issue that we all experience so
these are some numbers and you know
numbers get kind of blurring but I think
these numbers are so big that we have to
actually think about them so something
in this country some 5 million people
have Alzheimer's disease and an even
larger number worldwide some at least
five times this this number of people so
25 million there's new cases of
Alzheimer's every 7 seconds so if I talk
too long more people will have
Alzheimer's I wish I could just stop
talking and it will go away if only it
were that easy it's also an enormous
financial burden one that that risks
bringing down our whole health care
system these are some recent numbers a
conservative estimate is there's 200
billion dollars spent every year in the
US on Alzheimer's care there's actually
numbers from the Alzheimer's Association
that are about twice this big 400
billion these are huge numbers it's a
massive problem one of the reasons that
this is true sort of maybe it's
unfortunate but we actually this has
been alluded to earlier
we're getting better perhaps at taking
care of other illnesses which makes
Alzheimer's a bigger problem because
we're not good at at treating it at
fixing it and this is just a little
schematic showing them as a cause of
death
Alzheimer's is increasing over the last
decade whereas these other conditions
were actually making some progress on
and coupled with this this kind of trend
and the the relative increase in the
elderly population and of course
Alzheimer's is a disease of the elderly
this number which is already huge is
predicted to triple by the year 2050 in
this country so there's a huge need for
progress in Alzheimer's disease and I
think we all know that these are just
some numbers which which bring it home
so what do we do about Alzheimer's today
what is therapy for Alzheimer's and and
unfortunately we we have very few
weapons in the fight against Alzheimer's
today that we can use in the clinical
situation there are some approved
medications but they really provide
symptomatic benefit while you're on them
it helps a bit but it really doesn't
change the course of the disease so we
really don't have this a disease
modifying something that slows down or
reverses the disease and it's been
alluded to earlier that it's been sort
of a disappointing last several years or
decade of attempts to develop this kind
of disease modifying therapy have failed
to meet their ends and we still don't
have this kind of desperately needed
therapy so there there have been
responses to this and dr. hotus lured it
looted to this earlier one approach to
this idea why these things have failed
is that they've been used too late so
when the disease has already damaged the
brain to a point where it's hard to pull
things back and so now there are
attempts to treat earlier and trials
that the niña is supporting are trying
to make that happen and see if therapies
that we have will work at an
your stage I think a key thing is that
we need to find new drugs new targets
and test them and develop new therapies
and I'm going to emphasize the point
this depends on molecular understanding
and tell you about some of our
experience and I just want to make one
plant point here again already alluded
to there is this national plan to
address Alzheimer's disease and this is
important progress and it's expanding
our effort to make a difference to
discover these therapies but I would
point out even if under the best sort of
budgetary scenarios we may be able to
with this plan in place get to a
research effort that's still something
like one 1000 of what we already spend
on Alzheimer's care so I would emphasize
that more effort would be in all of our
interests it's the only way we're going
to get to these disease modifying
therapies so now I'm going to dive into
Alzheimer's and tell you about what we
do know about it approaches that we've
taken to it and where we might be able
to go forward so this idea of the
amyloid hypothesis of Alzheimer's
disease has been around now for a number
of years
there are kinks in its armor it's still
probably the most prevalent idea about
how Alzheimer's comes about amyloid
amyloid plaques are something that
probably most people have heard of this
sticky substance that deposits in the
brain the when when the brain of someone
who's died of Alzheimer's has studied in
the microscope there are these plaques
and I'll show you a picture of these in
a second
the major composition of these plaques
is this single peptide called amyloid
beta and this observation decades ago is
really what led to the idea that it may
be causative in the disease process this
single peptide amyloid beta would
somehow trigger the disease there's also
evidence from as mentioned earlier the
rare family
we're a single gene mutation can cause
Alzheimer's that's not what most
Alzheimer's is but a few families carry
a gene one of several genes where a
single mutation can introduce the
disease and those mutations by and large
are in the in the pathways that produce
a beta itself and more recently sort of
over the last five or so year there's
been a large consortium effort to study
the progression of Alzheimer's disease
again funded in part by the National
Institutes of Health and this kind of
study of the progression into
Alzheimer's so this is progression over
time from the schematic here
if one tracks patients as they develop
dementia go from cognitively normal to
mild cognitive impairment to dementia
really the first thing that's detected
whether by PET scanning or by CSF spinal
tap studies are changes in a beta so
it's the first event it proceeds
perhaps by decade the eventual
progression of dementia so there may be
later things that affect tau pathology
loss of brain tissue and eventual
dysfunction of the brain but this is
another reason to think that a trigger
very far upstream is this amyloid beta
peptide so how does this actually affect
the brain so this amyloid beta peptide
that I've been talking about is what
deposits in these plaques shown here in
red it comes from a gene called amyloid
precursor protein gets chopped up and
actually most of the things that have
been tried in the clinic recently that
haven't succeeded have tried to alter
this conversion from a PP to a beta or
try to pull this a beta out of the brain
so this material accumulates but there's
there's recently quite a bit of data
that there's several forms of this a
beta peptide when it's first made it's
simply a monomer and it floats
throughout and we actually all have
plenty of it actually no different than
in Alzheimer's patients really
then it can form small clumps called ala
gamers and I'm going to show you a
picture of those in a second or it can
go on to develop these huge plex and the
data suggests that it's actually these
oligomers that make the brain sick it's
not these plaques but it's the oligomers
that are unique to Alzheimer's disease
once they interact with neurons they can
impair synaptic function this eventually
leads to loss of neurons these tangles
neurofibrillary tangles in the brain and
it's this whole constellation of events
which actually produces the dementia now
a key part of this and something that
we've focused on is the idea that this
material is outside the nerve cell and
this sort of derangement of brain
function is happening inside of nerve
cells so how does this toxic material
trigger this bad stuff in a neuron I'm
going to give you a little better
picture of that and this is actually
from the niña website this is meant to
be a cell membrane here this a pipi
protein that I was telling you about
releases a beta and eventually it piles
up in these plaques that just gives you
some sense of scale and over here is the
normal brain each one of these big blobs
is the nerve cell they send out all
these processes you can think of them as
wires they conduct electricity they have
synaptic connections is called where one
cell touches another and an electrical
impulse that may travel down an axon
releases a chemical and is transmitted
to an electrical impulse in the second
cell and what seems to be happening the
evidence is that this a beta ala Goomer
can cause a disruption a dysfunction in
these synaptic connections so how does
this happen
what is this hologram or how does it
interact with the neuron that's what I'm
going to talk about now
these are actually some pictures of a
beta itself in an electron microscope
that we took the the single peptide
doesn't have any structure once it makes
these oligomers you can see these dots
and then when it makes this five
that piles up in plaques it looks
completely different now we don't really
know in a molecular sense how this is
organized but these are some models that
have been produced in part with
experimental evidence from David
Eisenberg's lab at UCLA and in this
state here there's really quite a
different structure the two a-beta
molecules one's pointed one way and
one's pointed another and they're
twisted in what's called a cylinder in
state the key point is that this blue
stuff is very different than this yellow
stuff and it's the blue stuff which may
be most toxic to the neurons so we
decided to look into this how does this
blue cylinder in toxic stuff interact
with neurons so what's shown here are
nerve cells in culture and what we did
was take this that it's as a beta
oolagah mer and tag it in a way that we
could see where it binds to the neurons
and you can see that it binds to neurons
and actually in the background here
there's other cells that it doesn't bind
to it binds only at a certain stage of
development when they start making
synapses the monomers don't bind so all
of these things suggested to us that
this oligomers had a specific place on
the neuron that it would stick a lot
like a lock and a key as a very specific
site and what we decided to do was to
try to figure out where this a beta
oolagah mer was binding on the neuron
what's the molecule that's responsible
for this and therefore allowing the
downstream bad effects of the oligomer
on neuronal function now this is a
little bit of molecular biology I'm just
gonna say a few words about we used a
method called expression cloning so the
basic idea is we didn't know what this
molecule was but we figured we check
every gene that there is expressed in
humans and the way we did this was to
take a cell that doesn't bind these a
beta oligomers and then one at a time
add the genes from the brain into
different cells and ask is there any
brain gene which will create these
binding sites similar to what
see on the neuron and there was one that
did and that's that's the result is
shown here so here these are
non-neuronal cells that don't bind a
beta so they're not dark and what we did
here was introduce this one gene which
I'm going to tell you about called prion
protein and when this protein is in
these particular cells now they'll bind
the a beta
oligomers in fact this binding event
looks just like what you see on a mature
neuron that has synapses so this single
prion protein was the only gene out of
some 200,000 that we screened through
that allowed this kind of binding and it
suggested to us that this would be
important in the function so let me tell
you just briefly what cellular prion
protein is so you may have heard of this
protein before because it can miss fold
and become infectious and in what's
called mad cow disease and in fact
there's evidence that this protein is
involved in the degeneration that
happens in this other brain disease so
we figured that's what's going on and in
Alzheimer's disease so we wanted to test
whether it's really important for the
synaptic dysfunction so we do that in a
of hippocampus so this is a part of the
brain that we put in a dish and we
record electricity and that's what's
shown here we stimulate if one of those
axons that you saw before and then we
record the synaptic connection and if
you do this in a healthy slice you can
record this electrical potential and
then if you stimulated a bunch and
record the potential it's greater this
is in essence sort of a memory that
happens in this chunk of brain tissue
and what had been shown before by a
number of labs was that if you do this
in the presence of this a beta oolagah
mer this potential is suppressed so they
can't remember the fact they got jolted
here and if you do this entire
experiment this effect of the a beta ala
Goomer in a piece of brain tissue that
genetically doesn't have prior
now there's no effect so the slices are
protected from the bad effect they
require prayin protein in order to have
this buyout effect another thing that
happens later is that synapses are
actually lost so this is zoomed in on
one of these pieces of a neuron and
culture and you can see each of these
little synapses and if you watch them
over several hours you can see that some
of them in the presence of a beta go
away they shrivel up they're lost this
is what we worry happens in the
Alzheimer's brain and so we did this
kind of experiment in neurons that don't
have prion protein and these synapses
aren't lost instead of losing 10 or 15%
of the synapses in this time period
without prion protein the neurons don't
lose their synapses and then we wanted
to see if it was important really for
something that's a little bit more like
dementia can we test memory now there's
not any perfect model of Alzheimer's
disease that we can test in the
laboratory but as mentioned before there
are these cases of Alzheimer's disease
where single genes can cause the effect
in humans and so these have been
transferred into mice and the mice get
plaques this is a piece of brain with a
bunch of those plaques and the mice get
memory loss and this is just a picture
of how we test memory so the mice go
into a big tank of water and somewhere
in the tank of water there's a platform
where they can climb out of the water
and after they've gone in the tanks a
bunch of times they learn that the
platform is here and so a healthy Mouse
when it's putting this thing will go
directly here and swim around to get out
of the water these are the Alzheimer's
mice that have they have these two genes
from human Alzheimer's cases they don't
know where to go they wander all over if
the mice have these Alzheimer's genes
and have plaques but they don't have
this prion protein now their memory is
over here it's it's improved so getting
rid of this prion protein might actually
benefit the ill effects of a beta Allah
Goomer and in fact a study at NYU showed
an antibody to prayin protein that these
Alzheimer's mice were corrected in their
memory and there's a NIH support now at
Yale to look for drugs that will block
this prion protein and achieve this kind
of genetic effect and also the drug
company AstraZeneca is working in that
direction with antibody so I told you
about this a beta oolagah mer binding to
prayin protein in studies that I'm not
going to go into we've actually mapped
out a couple of the molecular steps in
the nerve in the neuron right after this
happens and one of these is after prayin
protein is this molecule called M glue R
5 and a second one is this molecule
called fin and the reason I mentioned
these is being important these second
steps is that there are known compounds
that interact with each of them so this
molecule M tap blocks this blue protein
M glue r 5 and if this is given to these
same Alzheimer's mice it has a
beneficial effect so this is what's
scored here is actually multiple swims
as the animals are learning so wild-type
mice quickly learn where that hidden
platform was that is they go to the
small circle in that tank I showed you
before the Alzheimer's mice when they're
aged they don't do well here so they
learn slowly and additionally to having
bad memory later but if you treat these
Alzheimer's mice with this drug now they
learn just as well as healthy mice do
their time to get to that platform drops
right down and so this is something that
we can hope to to think about studying
in humans and they're actually here at
Yale it's been developed ligands pet
ligands that can image this particular
blue molecule in a human brain using
positron emission tomography and the
third step in this process is this
molecule fin kinase it's also critical
for this whole pathway and in fact here
again if you see the synapse loss in an
in a neuron that doesn't have
and it doesn't happen so this Finn
kinase is actually a member of a 4 or 5
kinase family called the Sartre family
it is a tie to this phospho to protein
and the tangles of Alzheimer's disease
so it really knits this the two major
pathologies of similary tangles and a
beta plaques together but importantly
there's a drug that targets this kinase
it was originally developed for cancer
it doesn't work too well in oncology but
it's safe and there's actually now a
Yale initiated trial to test this in
Alzheimer's disease and this has been
funded again by the National Institutes
of Health so I'm going to conclude here
and make a few points I told you about
these three molecules potential new
targets to approach the Alzheimer's
problem this is certainly there's many
approaches to the problem and I think we
need to pursue multiple lines of
evidence so we can actually get one of
these disease modifying therapies tau
pathology downstream here not only is it
downstream of this pathway once it's
triggered it can actually maintain
itself and spread and this is an active
area of an investigation to try to block
the ongoing tau pathology and as dr.
Hodes mentioned the immune system plays
a big role in regulating the responses
to a beta 2 tau and the entire synaptic
dysfunction that's in the brain it's
also a lot of evidence that Alzheimer's
disease interacts in a sort of multi
disease fashion with both diabetes and
vascular disease those are important
additional places for interaction and
we're also making a lot of progress in
other forms of dementia which teach us
something about Alzheimer's disease the
two major ones being Lewy body dementia
and frontotemporal dementia and in
conclusion I think we just we need to
know a lot more about the molecular
mechanisms so that we can get to a
disease modifying therapy to stop this
this burgeoning this tsunami of
Alzheimer's disease
threatens to overwhelm our healthcare
system and on a personal level is
devastating to those whose intellect is
robbed and I'm just gonna stop there and
mention the people in my lab who did
this work and most of this has been
supported by various organizations in
the NIH Thank You dr. Strittmatter